so in this video I want to talk about
steroid hormone synthesis in the adrenal
cortex and as I go through this you'll
notice I show all the different
structures and the enzyme names and some
of the details but I don't show the
stereochemistry in the structures
because just gets really complicated if
I want to show that and it's not really
super important for understanding what's
going on anyway now on the same token as
far as not wanting it to look super
complicated I also don't show the
coenzymes in each of the reactions but
it's worth noting there are lots of
NADPH and molecular oxygen molecules are
used by by the enzymes because the
enzymes are cytochrome p450 next
function oxidases and of course mixed
function oxidase is usually like the
oxygen as well as NADPH and we're
talking about reductive biosynthesis
here so it makes sense that we're using
NADPH that that there we go okay cool
now I've got a little slice of the
adrenal gland shown here and the adrenal
gland is actually two glands there's the
adrenal medulla kind of shown here in
the middle which we're not gonna really
talk too much about in this video the
adrenal medulla is sort of associated
with the the catecholamines like
norepinephrine and epinephrine but I'm
not like I said I'm not gonna really
talk about that too much the rest of
this kind of shown in these different
shades of pink here that is the the
adrenal cortex okay and that's what
we're gonna be talking about and so what
I want to do is kind of zoom in on the
adrenal cortex and the different layers
of it so let's zoom in so that yellow
sort of exterior is the capsule that's
just kind of what the adrenal gland is
sort of inside of right in that capsule
now there's a three layers and I'm
concerned with the the outermost layer
right sort of here and that darker pink
is the zona glomerulosa
otherwise we're gonna otherwise call it
the ZG I'm I'm probably just gonna say
glomerulosa
but the glomerulosa the zona glomerulosa
is gonna be important in making
mineralocorticoids okay so this one's
going to be important in making
it makes mineralocorticoids okay that's
mostly gonna be its thing now this this
next layer here the sort of in a lighter
pink that's gonna be the zona
fasciculata it's I've been in between
the other two layers or ZF and that's
gonna be important for mostly for making
glucocorticoids okay that's gonna be
making glucocorticoids okay though it
can also make androgens as well so I'll
put androgens here but primarily
glucocorticoids so put androgens now in
parentheses and then the innermost layer
is the again shown them at like the dark
portion that's the zona reticularis and
that's gonna be mostly important for
making makes androgens okay male sex
steroids but it can also make corticoids
okay so mainly mineralocorticoids
glucocorticoids and androgens okay now
let's actually get into the reactions so
we're making steroid hormones and
steroid hormones are steroids and so
they come from cholesterol because of
course cholesterol provides the steroid
nucleus right the sort of a b c d ring
combination that is necessary to build
all these different steroids and so
cholesterol though is not really
committed to steroid hormone synthesis
specifically they can give rise to all
different types of steroids and of
course also steroid hormones is a subset
of steroids but like I said it's not
committed to start at home alone
synthesis well what we have to do in
order to commit to making steroid
hormones is create this molecule down
here pregnenolone and that's gonna that
can be made in all three of the zonas of
the adrenal cortex and that's gonna be
done by cholesterol sidechain cleavage
enzymes also called des malaise okay so
this is an important enzyme here
okay and you'll notice what it does and
I were actually gonna show the numbers
on the cholesterol here as well as all
the other molecules that that enzyme is
gonna remove the six carbon six carbons
from this chain out here from
cholesterol and when it removes six
carbons you're gonna end up going from a
27 carbon molecule to a 21 carbon
molecule and we're also gonna take
carbon number 20 and and oxidize it to a
carbonyl okay
so that's all going to be done by that
sidechain cleavage enzyme or des malaise
to give bringing alone and pregnenolone
once that's made that's basically
committed to producing steroid hormone
specifically it's the 21 carbon
precursor to steroid hormones okay now
since we're talking about the adrenal
cortex this enzyme being catalyzing the
rate limiting or committed step of of
steroid hormone synthesis is regulated
it's specifically stimulated by
adrenocorticotropic hormone or ACTH
which comes from the anterior pituitary
and that of course is stimulated by it's
it's stimulated to be made and released
from the anterior pituitary by
corticotropin-releasing hormone from the
hypothalamus okay
cool so now it's also worth noting that
LH can also stimulate at the decimal ace
but Lewton LH or luteinizing hormone is
important in the gonads okay not here
the adrenal cortex was drew why I drew
it in different color to kind of
indicate that that specifically
stimulates the fika cells the seekest
the fetus cells in the ovaries in
females and the Leydig cells in the
testes of males okay but once we have
this reaction happen again it can happen
in any of the zones we get pregnant
alone and we basically committed to
steroid hormone production in the cortex
okay and of course again I don't know if
I mentioned it but adrenocorticotropic
hormone stimulates the growth of the
adrenal cortex as well as the
synthesis and release of steroid
hormones from the cortex right so
sometimes I'll just say it'll stimulate
the growth and secretory activity of the
adrenal cortex okay so now we're gonna
kind of go through each of the zones
separately to kind of see what steroid
hormones were made there so let's start
in the zona glomerulosa so we've already
shown making pregnenolone so let's
scroll down a bit and see the next
steroid that's made so we can see here
that we've got progesterone okay so what
happened here going from pregnenolone to
progesterone well this is gonna be
catalyzed by three beta hydroxy steroid
dehydrogenase isomerase sometimes called
four or five isomerase out here it's not
just isomerase and that should that'll
make sense in just a second but this
enzyme name will actually make sense
because carbon number three three beta
hydroxy stereo dehydrogenase card with
carbon number three has this hydroxyl
group and that's oxidized so it's
telling you where that dehydrogenase
reaction is occurring
that's the oxidation there and then the
four or five isomerase this double bond
here between carbons five and six is
moved to to be between carbons four and
five so hence the four five isomerase
there so basically it turns the carbon
three alcohol to a carbon eel and it
moves the double bond from between five
and six to four and five hence the four
five isomerase so now we have
progesterone now what the next reaction
is going to make eleven deoxy Cora
Koster own and this is gonna be done by
twenty-one alpha hydroxylation by the
way before I keep going you'll notice
that I have these uh alphas and betas in
parentheses and that's because sometimes
you you may or may not see those okay
you might just see twenty-one
hydroxylase you might even see something
different than what's shown here mostly
you should see the same thing but that
refers to the stereochemistry which I'm
not showing here but um I figured I just
mentioned that in case you began to
freak out about that which hopefully you
probably wouldn't anyway so uh
progesterone is turned into eleven deoxy
quarter Koster owned by twenty-one alpha
hydroxy listen this is named this a
enzyme name makes sense because carbon
21 up here it's gonna
have a hydroxyl group attached perhaps I
should use a different color just to
kind of make it clear here yeah so 21 at
that position we're adding a hydroxyl
group so that name should make sense and
that gives us 11 deoxy core DeCoster own
now 11 deoxy quartic Ostrom or do c or
dot this is the first mineralocorticoid
that we're making and this is
specifically a weak mineralocorticoid
okay it's not a strong one but it is a
mineral accord way nonetheless okay then
we have 11 beta hydroxylase that's going
to add a hydroxyl group at the 11
position to give corticosteroids so 11
deoxy quarter costs around is just
quarter koster own without the hydroxyl
group at the eleventh position okay but
now this is also a mineralocorticoid
again though it's a weak one it's a weak
mineralocorticoid okay and then we're
gonna turn core decoster own into
aldosterone with the 18 alpha
hydroxylase also known as aldosterone
synthase and I think that's probably the
more important thing to know but at the
18 position we go from just having this
methyl group to having an aldehyde so
it's not really adding a hydroxyl group
and if it was added initially as a
hydroxyl Google was oxidized to that all
the height but aldosterone and things to
be elde
and aldosterone refers to that aldehyde
so now a duster own is actually a strong
mineral accord okay so that's gonna be
pretty important so we added that uh
that cog Neil at the 18 position and we
made out Austin now something that's
really important to know about dosterone
synthase is that it's specific to the
zona glomerulosa it's only in the
glomerulosa
okay so it's super important to
recognize here and that means that only
the zona glomerulosa
can make aldosterone okay so this is
unique to the zona glomerulosa okay
now I was also run of course being a
mineral of corticoid
stimulates sodium reabsorption and
potassium secretion and
protons excretion if I said secretion I
meant excretion sorry about that but
anyway this is happening at the distal
tubules
distal tubules and collecting duct in
the kidney collecting duct in the kidney
and of course that's important in
increasing blood pressure right there
the sodium reabsorption eventually leads
to water retention right so we have
increased water and then I'll increase
blood volume and that'll eventually be
important in increasing blood pressure
and that actually really is something
that's actually pretty important and
that is the fact that angiotensin
angiotensin 2 which is a molecule that's
really important in increasing blood
pressure actually stimulates this
specific enzyme aldosterone synthase
okay in fact that's one of the ways that
it actually contributes to increasing
the blood pressure it stimulates the
production of nos Tyrone which of course
triggers sodium ion reabsorption and
water retention as a sort of consequence
and eventually increasing blood pressure
as a consequence okay so that's
important to recognize there cool so but
again the aldosterone so this is unique
to the zona glomerulosa cool so that's
what's going on in the zona glomerulosa
now let's look at the vesicular
you